والصلاه على المغترمه
[موسيقى]
يا رب هذا لطف منك يا اشملني زائر مدينه
هررت تفاجئه انها ليلا تلبس حله جديده
تعبر في كل تفاصيلها عن تنوعها اذ تعلو في
احد البيوت ابتهالات ومدح للنبي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم
فالتصوف متجذر في نفوس ساكنها وابنيتها
وكل ما تراه من حولك
عفوا
نتمنى ان نكون من المتصوفين كما كان
اسلافنا من قبل هنا في هارون فالتصوف ليس
طريقه دينيه وحسب لدى الهرويين بل هو
اسلوب للحياه اباؤنا علمونا ان نلتزم
بجميع الاداب مثلا نحن حتى اليوم وان كبرت
اعمارنا نستجيب للاوامر بنظرات من شيوخنا
ونشتغل في جميع اوقاتنا بالذكر خاصه في
وقت ما بين المغرب والعشاء الجميع هنا
مهتم بقراءه وحفظ القران الكريم والذكر
والاوراد اليوميه خاصه الصلاه على النبي
مع الاسره فالارتباط بالتصوف اصبح من
العادات في هرر ولكن في السنوات الاخيره
هناك بعض العوامل الدخيله والعولمه التي
اثرت على المجتمع الهرر
الى وحاره